volodymyr zelensky le président
ukrainien a réagi l'ukraine ne laissera
pas la russie s'approprier la victoire
sur le nazisme c'est ce qu'il a déclaré
ce matin on va tout de suite partira
kiev retrouver bastien ono et notre
envoyé spécial bastien bonjour on a
entendu vladimir poutine encore une fois
justifié sa guerre comment on appréhende
cette journée du 9 mai côté ukrainien il
ya de l'inquiétude on craint une
intensification de l'offensive russe
tout à fait oui et le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est que vladimir poutine n'a pas
apporté de réponse on ne sait pas ce qui
va se passer aujourd'hui au cours des
prochains jours il y avait plusieurs
possibilités le spectre d'une guerre
nucléaire qui avait été écartée
notamment par les services de
renseignements américains et ukrainiens
qui disait que et bien la russie n'était
pas en train de mobiliser son arsenal il
y a le fait que les troupes biélorusses
sont en train de s'entraîner pour un
autre aimant d'urgence à la frontière
avec l'ukraine qui s'était déjà produit
en compagnie des troupes russes peu
avant le début de la guerre ici en
ukraine et puis il ya aussi le fait que
les navires de guerre russes c'est un
navire qui peuvent lancer des missiles
sont tous mobilisés dans la mer noire
selon des médias ukrainiens qui les ont
vus quitter leur port d'attache
notamment dans la crimée qui est annexée
depuis 2014 par la russie donc beaucoup
de possibilités vous pour l'instant bien
très peu de réponses alors ici on
s'attend à un redoublement des
bombardements notamment sur l'est et le
sud du pays mais aussi un petit peu
ailleurs puisque au cours des dernières
semaines il ya eu une intensification
des bombardements dans l'ouest et sur le
centre de l'ukraine le maire de la
capitale qui à vitali klitschko
l'annoncé 1 il faut faire attention
bombardements il le dit aux ukrainiens
qui ont tendance à ne plus aller se
cacher dans les abris lorsqu'il ya des
alertes ou le monde lourdement et bien
là il faut les respecter ces alertes il
faut y faire attention il peut y avoir
une intensification des bombardements au
cours des prochaines heures et au cours
des prochains jours mais voilà depuis ce
matin et c'est la première fois depuis
que je me trouve en ukraine il n'y a pas
eu d'alerté au bombardement à kiev alors
est ce que cela signifie quelque chose
ou non et bien on le saura au cours des
prochaines heures merci beaucoup bastia
1 renault